the name is Bill Pullman you're an  intelligence officer the CIA done easier  to remember number one youngster Dutch  program you can find Muslim anytime  anywhere where did you put it that is  all we need to know I don't really  remember nothing  who are you  they stop your husband in my head  looking for details that he knew before  he was killed  Washington for the invasion with the  graveyards and you feel what Billy felt  he loves so much  Thank You buddies at stake  better they go to Mary  in theaters equal 15 does this trio  Tigers do business major Rica gem Soviet  village name via and an oven steel oven  sound on Ivan after Cynthia